aujourd'hui nous allons en apprendre un
peu plus sur l'allocation de scolarité
cette aide du département co-financée
par le Fond Social Européen intervient
pour le règlement des frais d'études
pour les étudiants boursiers
départementaux allons à la rencontre de
Lydia jeune et diplômé en master qui en
a bénéficié et qui va pouvoir nous en
dire un peu plus suivez-moi
[Musique]
la location de scolarité intervient pour
le règlement des frais d'études
supérieures à 1000 euros c'était
financière du département est également
cumulable avec la bourse départementale
ce dispositif vise les parcours dit
d'excellence des bouchons sur un diplôme
final de niveau bac + 5
[Musique]
bonjour Lydia bonjour alors dites nous
que vous a apporté ce dispositif et bien
écoutez ces dispositifs n'a été très
bénéfique m'a permis de payer
entièrement mes
frais et comment faire pour s'inscrire
et bénéficier de cette aide j'ai fait
mon inscription donc j'ai envoyé tous
les documents nécessaires par la suite
j'ai attendu la réponse et qui vient qui
est arrivé au bout de un ou deux mois et
que retenez-vous de ce dispositif et
bien je retiens de ce dispositif qui est
très bénéfique pour les étudiants qui
n'ont pas forcément les moyens de payer
leur formation eux-mêmes avec la c'est
assez compliqué pour moi parce que ma
formation elle était très coûteuse et
sans cette aide j'aurais peut-être pas
pu continuer mes études merci Lydia de
rien
l'allocation de scolarité permet à des
étudiants remplissant les conditions
générales d'accès aux aides
départementales d'être soutenu pour le
règlement de leur prix de scolarité un
accompagnement qui vise encourager les
parcours dit d'excellence
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Alexandre alors
dites-nous qui peut bénéficier de
l'allocation de scolarité alors la
location de scolarité destinée aux
étudiants réunionnais bénéficiaires de
la bourse départementale dont les frais
de scolarité sont supérieurs à 1000
euros et qui poursuivent un parcours
d'études dit d'excellence où il n'y a
pas de diplôme intermédiaire école
d'ingénieurs école de commerce ou
programme de grandes écoles cette aide
est également destinée aux étudiants qui
souhaitent poursuivre leurs études en
Master soit bac + 4 bac + 5 et quand
sont prévus les inscriptions pour
bénéficier de la location de scolarité
alors vous pouvez vous inscrire sur
notre plateforme netbourse.reu à partir
du 30 avril et ce jusqu'au 31 décembre
chaque année la demande se fait lors de
la constitution de votre dossier de
bourse départementale en renseignant le
montant des frais de scolarité au regard
des informations fournies et validation
de l'éligibilité de l'étudiant il lui
sera réclamé un justif comme par exemple
une facture à quitté et bien il y a quel
montant s'élève cette aide alors le
montant varie entre 2000 et 6000 euros
maximum cette aide est calculée à partir
du revenu fiscal du foyer de l'étudiant
et bien évidemment du montant les frais
de scolarité renseigner et justifier par
les étudiant très bien merci Yann merci
à vous
la location de scolarité est un
dispositif attribué en complément de la
bourse départementale afin de favoriser
la mobilité des jeunes au sein de
l'Espace économique européen une façon
pour le département de contribuer à
l'excellence et à la réussite éducative
de nos étudiants
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur l'allocation de
scolarité n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes
les coordonnées qui s'affichent sur
votre écran le département des
générations c'est fini si vous souhaitez
revoir cet épisode ainsi que les
précédents rendez-vous sur nos sites et
nos réseaux sociaux
la semaine prochaine marronnier est à la
rencontre d'une bénéficiaire de l'aide
au rapatriement de dépouille mortel une
aide financière du département pour
accompagner et soutenir les familles
réunionnaises heurté par la perte d'un
proche
[Musique]